the conic characters take one being
human my first role was I played a
werewolves ex-fiance who had epilepsy in
being human the pilot for BBC three and
I wore a shiny purple Parker and of some
reason I had sideburns that rolled
around like Lisa Stansfield I was very
lucky to get it because I didn't I left
dramas gone didn't have an agent or
anything so a casting director had seen
me in my showcase and got me in for the
audition and if I didn't get that part I
wouldn't have got my agent or anything
so I was very very lucky to get it even
there was a very odd and stressful
experience
it was just like I'd never done it
before I didn't understand it and I went
to theater school so I understood
theater but then I didn't understand
anything no one tells you like when you
get on set what it's gonna be like and
will you rehearse or will you not and I
just didn't get it
I learnt very very very fast on that job
because I was very scared little
director Amy Dorrit was this really this
Dickens character as a Dickens
adaptation and she was incredibly sweet
and incredibly kind and tiny and that
she only able to things whether people's
completely selfless I mean I like to
think I'm kind too but I'm definitely
bullshi and kind of loud and RC and what
at the time and Amy just wasn't that at
all and so I didn't see it but they just
sort of coached me through and then I
got the job and Deauville of all she was
the director of that she even sort of
made my career really and so suddenly I
was yeah on the backlot Pinewood Studios
and they'd entirely built all the
streets that were in the Marshall C
prison and I walked round and imagine
while it was like everybody does he said
I want to have dress all and go for not
enough Narns and walk round
has brought this child to my door I know
I am small but I am quite grown up she
understood you were a lady I was sort of
the youngest person on set I was so new
I have no idea what was going on I used
to have my lunch in the trailer with all
the eight-year assistant directors of
lvad he's cuz I didn't want to be alone
and now I love being in my trailer on my
own but I was that high come sit with
you it was just magical so lucky to have
been given that experience it was really
magical will fall peter kozminski of
work with him twice and he creates an
environment where the actor is respected
and he doesn't try and inhibit you in
any way he never puts the slate on at
the beginning of a tape you just somehow
start and so it's always really special
working with him I love working with him
those who've been made can be unmade and
I loved the book so much and I was so
precious about them that throughout that
whole thing I was just a really strong
critic of myself which ultimately I
think worked because every decision I
took I questioned whether that was the
right decision and therefore wondered if
there was a different way of doing it
like it forced me to kind of the way I
normally worked to kind of think outside
of that way of working and it was I got
to work them I try Lance is an absolute
genius and very rare talent and it'll
always be a really special job so I
found out I was pregnant on that job
because I suddenly one morning went to
work and it was the the day of my
execution and I woke up and I was I just
really want a bacon and egg McMuffin and
so on the way to work I dry like a
drive-through got bacon egg McMuffin and
I was like this is really weird and I'm
like gonna have you know technically
fiction we have my head chopped off it's
not the right thing to be doing
the crown it's very rare that you get a
part which I felt like even though it
was my age I felt like she was a
different age like I felt older I felt
she was much more of a character that I
had to kind of put on I suppose you know
everything about the way I looked
everything about the way I stood and
moved and the way I spoke they expressed
myself everything was completely
different had to relearn an entire
person my name is Lizabeth in long live
Queen Elizabeth
I made friends for life on that on that
job so it will always be you know so
special to me first man I mean
Damian else is looking really good it
was how difficult it was to fake it
there is no way there is face the amount
of effort that that they went to to
recreate the moon landing is obscene you
know they they built the moon like
craters in a quarry in Atlanta in order
to get the particular type of light that
you get which even doesn't compare but
that looks beautiful short on IMAX here
they had to build a light that was a
replica of the Sun and it exploded twice
it was so strong and they had to shoot
the entire thing at night it's easier to
go to the moon than it is to fake the
moon landing you're a bunch of boys
making models out of balsa wood you
don't have anything under control it
takes a lot of work getting to point
where you you've rejected the idea that
you can ever be American and the guilt
of not being American is huge it's a
whole different frame of reference you
know there's no shortcuts not that there
ever are when you're playing another
character like an English character but
you know you have to relearn everything
about a place in its geography and what
that means about then how people hold
themselves and express themselves and
what their values are and how that
shapes the person and I take all that
for granted when I'm working at home you
know I'm playing an English person
because I kind of just inherently know
that that's the case but you we do have
to change a lot about your state of mind
and the rhythm in which you express
yourself and stuff it's not just the
accent
Damian sells an old soul he's been here
before he's just not young in that way
he is young younger than me but he's
such a mature filmmaker and so in
control of the process and what he wants
and so trusting of his actors Ryan is
just the kindest most generous possible
person you could ever try and act
opposite yeah I was a real equal on that
set which she would think is not they've
worked together before they are who they
are you know I was definitely like kind
of going in going
thanks for having me and they just made
me feel so welcome all the time
unsane steven soderbergh just makes it
so easy and we both you know he said you
know how did you feel about going to New
York ten days and making a student film
and I was like yes please cuz I was
coming off the crown and I didn't even
know that was good he never said it was
gonna come out that film um should never
have believed him and so I didn't know
what it was I just went into it thinking
this is just for me and I just played
and I just he would say okay run down
this corridor of like great or he'd say
okay now you've just taken loads of
drugs and you've got loads of side
effects like great and so I just got to
just be really free really and it worked
for that because we shot chronologically
and there was lots in it that you know
as watching it as an audience member
like why is she going into that room why
is she doing that but if I was just in
the state of mind I'm just going going
with it and going with the flow and so
it really helped with that character
please send help thank you
do you know how many cars the cops get
like that every week those are from
crazy people Steven Soderbergh just
brilliant and I find him really
inspiring the way he doesn't want to do
anything with reputation in mind he
doesn't care about what people think of
him as a filmmaker he loves film and
he's interested in film and so he will
continue to kind of challenge himself
and educate himself about it and so
doing that was I just want a piece of
that yeah I'd do it all again tomorrow
absolutely loved it
breathe we shot it in seven weeks it was
completely immersive I loved working
with Andrew and Andy it was a very very
tender story and and the producer was
the child of these two people died on a
rubber camera dish so I got to know
Diana and I got to know Robin through
his son and his his wife and from the
beginning it felt really like nothing
else I'd ever done every day was
emotional every day was beautiful for
some reason or another it was a
ridiculous experience you know they
would we were filming in the British
countryside and then we went to Africa
in Africa we were constantly it seemed I
had the only my only memory of it is
that we were constantly filming at
sunset or sunrise
there was nothing in between I just it
was one of the most beautiful filming
experience I've ever had it was it was
unreal the girl and the spiders when I'd
read all the books and then I watched
all three Swedish films and I watched
the David Fincher film as well so I
would say I was an avid fan but I mean
enough to first horror film and read all
the books so yeah definitely a fan and I
just think she he created such a unique
character who people have really adored
for such a long time it's pretty
incredible if anything unexpected should
happen to her this video will be sent to
you